on est là pour le démontage comme ça
intéressant on a vu les deux pour
l'accueillir complet ou maintenant pour
le voit se démonter non j'ai très bien
des dollars à chaque samedi à skis
mauvaise
très joli jeu
carrier l'oeuvre originale oui bah oui
oui évidemment mais
saccage des choses alors là après qu'est
ce qu'il a voulu dire
c'est bien de l'encré
[Applaudissements]
moi je suis hyper est venu en fait je
savais pas que c'était le dernier jour
donc je suis venu à hyper vite en
pensant que vous avez encore un peu de
temps et donc je suis venu très vite
quand j'ai vu ces derniers jours et
c'est à nice que je
quand j'avais 8 ans
on
[Musique]
j'avais été faire choper
pourquoi et pourquoi j'étais bien
et voilà du coup la de revoir une oeuvre
les cristaux alors qu'en plus ils sont
plus là les landes
je suis assez content voir malgré
ce serait bien les jours